what would it take you to play of like a
straightforward villain because even
though you've played so many anti-heroes
over the course of your career I don't
think I've ever seen you play a
full-blown villain before well it's
funny that you say that because what's
interesting about the value universe is
that there are storylines in which blood
shot is the villain if you look at from
the harbingers perspective and that's
one of the things that's cool and
dynamic about it so you might be ahead
of everyone else in but you might be
ahead of and I remember Steven Spielberg
wanted me to play a go of it and really
Universal shot at that but you might be
ahead of everyone in that you can you're
talking about blood shot you talk about
your skepticism going into the movie and
how delighted you were leaving that
character is rich enough and in the unit
universe there are storylines and that's
kind of what one of the reasons why this
character was so dynamic for me because
the potential to actually I like the
sound of that I also like what a force
you are in the industry because I also
covered the last witch hunter pretty
heavily and I adored that experience in
your passion for the project so as
someone who never ever stops how do you
overcome when something doesn't pan out
the way you hope and forge forward and
winds up with more fast movies and also
watch shot now such a good question it's
such a good question and I will say just
recently
I came to the realization that you know
and so often were so consumed or we buy
into the kind of the studio objective of
box office box office box office and
when when a last witch hunter comes out
and it doesn't destroy the box office
you are under the old thinking would go
well maybe I should focus on something
else but nowadays what's fascinating is
that movies find you somehow and no
wooden cell find me guilty in the
theatre but it will find you and as a
artist I am the the more experienced I
get the more I am appreciating just the
fact that my work somehow finds you and
that you get to experience it at your
own time at your own pace and I'm less
concerned and maybe it's because Vakil
it's maybe it's because I'm a part of
Avengers oh I'm a part of Disney I'm
purported you know guardians and I'm a
part of fast and I have had so much of
that wonderful experience that I think
the higher thinking becomes when when
people tell the hurt they love the witch
hunter and they want to see Michael
Caine and I'd go and do another one I
don't
Wow then and then Lionsgate is coming
and saying we're putting a writer on for
the next word that's kind of cool and so
if you were a testament about is if you
were so
sand with just the box office and now
delivering something that you feel proud
of or that you want to share just your
reaction along to bloodshot makes me
want to share with him him him and her
or all of them right the whole world but
if you were self just softly thinking
about box office you wouldn't release
bloodshot right now that's still her
only way to put it is that a soldier
doesn't decide went and where he's
deployed and there in lies the spirit of
who blood shop is that's that's kind of
that's kind of the rationality almost
crazy and and saying no we need movies
so III and this is just recent by the
way but it's funny that you mentioned
last which I do because I'm in a meeting
with Lionsgate and they're actively
creating the sequel as Richard but
that's like did it gazillions of dollars
it didn't you know and so it's one of
those things that with that kind of with
that maturity and that kind of being so
much in this business and doing what
you've said keep pushing forward and I'm
not I'm not whether I succeed or not I'm
no longer interested in making movies I
solely I'm trying to make a masterpiece
each